I have been using the Rebuilder for their Opity regularly, and I think I'm doing it right now.
I do feel tingles when using it, but sometimes I also feel a Z, or I know I have a tumor.
Is it possible the Rebuilder could encourage growth in a tumor?
No, no, it's not possible because it is firing at the frequency of the nerves, the neurons.
So what you don't want to have growth in a tumor is you don't want to have vascular growth
into a tumor which would be stimulating vascular endothelial growth factor. We had a question
about that a few weeks ago, and that's why you wouldn't take nitric oxide. So you don't take
nitric oxide if you have cancer because you'll be stimulating vascular endothelial growth factor,
and you'll be stimulating vessel growth into a solid tumor which is going to cause the tumor to
grow. The Rebuilder is not going to do that, so you don't have to worry about that.
Yeah, there's no negatives about that with cancer, so I think you're safe.